drive and drive and drive and drive and
drive and drive and drive and drive
drive and drive and drive and drive and
drive and drive and drive and drive
drive drive drive and drive driving
driving driving to go get food is what I
like dude come on
I shared your music with the world what
why did you want no whoa all right guys
welcome to my city New York City
greatest city the world
I mean debatable well I mean definitely
Chicago's number one I'm gonna take this
my favorite spots to eat at we're gonna
go all across the borough's nice
Brooklyn Manhattan the other three yes
you guys know that I'm like a burger
mania yeah yeah of course
so my favorite burger joint in all of
New York it's called burger joint huh
and the catch is it's the Assizes hotel
the ketchup is inside this hotel it's
like such a perfect that's only cool
that is in a hotel yeah I love that we
get a room a little hidden gem I know
about I feel like I'm in my old basement
might we all raise our burgers yes no
take our dog girl bite you see
I see on the other side
this is incredible incredible this place
is different this is the joint gonna see
something fun
yeah cute is this gluten free by the way
whoa you are very close i I got this
my backup camera has no girls me I am a
backup camera alright on to the next
be careful road driving this joint cool
I know the people here they treat me
real well nice you're about to be
treated like a cake I come here a lot
like five times a week
right yes I know you sometimes I cannot
pay for the tab they let me put it on a
tab so all of this is going on your tab
today I wish I was on I wish I'd attend
anywhere oh here it is
oh yeah everything let's taco bump it
out
talk about Tiger bone tackle bone Joey
this doesn't taste like pizza could you
at least give us a hint of where we're
going next
it's triangle cheese I got cheese ah hot
dog the Far pizza in Brooklyn there's
the first pizza there's the first pizza
we've done yes this is very this is the
best piece in the entire city
now prepare your taste buds yes and your
bellies for a royal treat this is a very
high quality product this scares me some
of the best be god haha no all right
guys now that we've had the official New
York slice let's cap off the day with an
official in New York sunset
do that create the beats in the garden
for me
I've eaten more meals with you guys than
I have with anyone else